what I'd like to do is perhaps kind of
tie back to the question that I asked at
the beginning of my introduction of the
talks and maybe also then ask the
different presenters to ask each other
questions or talk a little bit about the
overlap in their work and then we'll
open it up to to the audience and to
give the audience some camp to raise
some questions so I think in all your
work would struck me in throughout the
talks the question of illness death and
decay plays a role in thinking about
materiality and thinking about life and
bodies and so I'm curious to hear you
talk a little bit more about how you
think about that relationship and in
also kind of the effort of redirecting
focus of the liveliness of matter I
think both in the last two talks that we
heard there was a very strong push to
kind of think about matter as history
and as social relations and so I'm
curious to hear you talk a little bit
more about the relationship between
damage death and deliverable in your own
work and may be sure who would like I
mean I think you know for for me
thinking about money and about
relationships of value damage death and
decay are not necessarily negative
values if they lead to replacement
reproduction next growth what's the the
fighting thing is to think about sort of
freezing or cutting like the moments
were those efforts to to freeze in time
that flow of relationship that flow of
relationality or to cut off certain
relations so if you think about kind of
contemporary Western
most money really being an effort to cut
off say the relations between humans and
the natural world that's a problem and
we sort of see the obvious kind of
outcome of that problem which is why
these proposals for ecological monies
are so interesting they put the the
physical and livable stuffs of the
planet back into that that relation so
you know even if they even if they won't
fly doesn't really matter right they
bring to mind again that there's that
connection
you don't need an ecological money to do
that I think you can do that with the
kind of money we have now it just takes
the kind of something on the light
switch of that sort of recognition of
those other relations yeah I think to me
death is is sort of the foundation of
ethics because because it makes life so
valuable you know and so I Kairi with
you bill that I think it's when you when
you try to freeze things I mean I'm sure
at MIT they are they're they're finding
a way to make us immortal but I'm not
I'm not sure I'm interested you know
despite the tragedies of life and I but
I do appreciate trying to attack cancer
cells because you know I've had cancer
probably a lot of people misery with had
cancer
it's it's a derivative because of all
the poisons we put in our environment
and also because of the nature of life
really you know the growth of cells etc
getting out of hand
but what was the question about damage
death and decay and the livable did I
answer good idea I think I'm somewhere
there somewhere in there right in the
vicinity but I just want to say that
when I I'm also a little bit troubled
about natural capital and and trying to
you know and just looking at the
ecosystems as as a kind of fund of
services you know that can be quantified
and you know when I proposed soil as as
a foundation of a currency I'm doing a
thought experiment you know I'm just
saying like what is
what is value was based on something
that actually we need and that we need
to nurture you know and that we need to
take care of like what is what would
change what would have to change you
know if it wasn't like oh you know
actually de facto - to the price of oil
which is like killing us you know it
might be worth mentioning the claire
brought one of her in got winner in many
ways materially proving the absurdity of
the project right when Isabelle Caro on
the way over here you know despite a
mountain of bubble wrap and oversized
suitcase and everything but it's
downstairs and it's um you can touch it
all right you know it's a good stuff um
yeah I mean I think you know from the
science perspective I guess the
life-and-death question you kind of see
it a little bit more as a binary thing
but but you know I think what was
interesting that we were talking about
is how a lot of the artworks and things
like that with the science actually you
know they decay over time and it's
interesting to think about how to convey
those kind of concepts with living
materials like soil or like bacteria
that aren't necessarily going to be
preserved and and how did that sort of
communicate these kind of concepts of
death and things like that
so do the periodic specific to you're
working through the bacteria ever
misbehave I'm wondering about that yeah
they do so yeah I guess one of the the
biggest things that we cite again is
their ability to evolve you know we do
program them and we do try and control
them as much as possible but you put
them in some situation like a tumor and
they may decide they want to stop making
the drug right and so
we have to try and come up with clever
ways to prevent that from happening and
some of those ways include things like
having them kill themselves when they
don't do a certain function but then
there's also this alternative approach
of actually allowing them to grow and
evolve and to use that as a function and
a way to direct their ability to you
know treat for detective ease that's
what happens naturally so I'd like to
ask the presenters whether they have
maybe questions for each other first
before we open it to the audience I'll
offer an observation I mean when one
thing that strikes me in seeing these
presentations in relationship to each
other is just how unwieldy life is and
how unwieldy the definition may be like
is it that which eventually dies as
Claire points out you know prom probably
right but I was really interested in
your presentation to understand you know
that it's sort of in the aggregate of
the mass of bacteria that they start to
recognize themselves and fluoresce and
that there always seems to be the sort
of communicability and series of
relations whether it's a circulatory
relation or ecosystemic relation or a
bacterial community that defines the
approach to life through the course of
materiality in each of the presentations
to that yeah definitely I mean I think
that most of these functions are
happening at the community level whether
it's you know in the soil there's tons
of bacteria interacting with one another
and they talk to one another and they
also trying to interfere each other
signals to gain an advantage and they
also do these things to form biofilms
and aggregate
and to infect a host to know when you
know a host is not necessarily in the
fully immuno competent faith and to
invade and do things like that so it
really is I think you know always about
the collective behavior of bacteria and
so people on my field are just starting
to realize how how can you start to
think about designing ecosystems with
bacteria rather than designing a single
cell at a time you anthropomorphize them
yeah I guess I said mintus but they're
doing you know they're to have different
life cycles because like the bacteria
they divide I call them daughters right
and they continue to grow and there's
not like a lineage like we have and the
sense of lifetime is very different like
you know cells have these mechanisms
where they can only divide a certain
amount of times but bacteria can
continue to divide and they don't have
this concept of like a fixed lifetime
yeah we made that up
I was just thinking about how in both of
your presentations there is a sense of
kind of a collaborative consciousness
that emerges from the interactions of
the bacteria on the one hand and then
the stuff in the soil on the other and
how do you think about that at look at a
kind of meta level what is the kind of
collaborative consciousness of the
mycelium and the plants and the little
bits of disabuse bits and pieces of this
and that each of which are also in
various stages of living or decomposing
right so not all the things in your in
your slide are are alive but they are
because they're colonized by these
things that are alive that are turning
them into something else so this is
incredible continuum here that then at
this next level has I mean I'm trying
not to anthropomorphize it but has these
kind of other other existence that's
really asking to think about it is and
like even like the mycelium you know
that
as it extends the pipes when it's
growing it's made of carbon and so it
actually sequester's a lot of carbon in
the soil and by disrupting the soil we
release a lot of carbon in our tillage
agriculture but so it is it's sort of
like it's living and dying the mycelium
I mean it's still like there's the end
that's growing and then there's the
carbon pipes that it's leaving behind
and and it's all used but it's not all
alive you know I mean just really
practically used like in use or used
like used clothes okay
oh no yeah well yeah it's in use in use
which I guess also is like use close but
close I also really liked your the
expression the pickling off matter
yeah well that's some pasta right yeah
yeah it is it is interesting you know I
I'm thinking I just remembering that one
time when I needed a job at one point in
my life I guess in my early 30s I worked
for the Bronx Zoo and I was an artist
for the zoo and made the artificial
environment right the fake rocks and
vines and trees and everything and it
always had this very strange feeling of
it's likely its life likeness just
seemed to scream I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dead now and we like you look at those
environments and see the animals of
course we they have nothing to do in
captivity except like destroy their
environment so they have to do so so you
have to make these very durable things
you know like you could actually put the
real plants in there and sometimes they
do but then they get ripped out you know
and eaten or whatever by the poor
animals and and so you make this white
thing and they try to make it as
lifelike it's like you know very similar
to like I mean all the techniques are
very advanced you know and it but it
seems so it always feels kind of dead
right
I mean very similarly
like whenever you imitate life it seems
so hey well it's uncanny
it's be uncanny right right and as we
were hearing yesterday about artificial
intelligence and like will we make it
look like humans which is so creepy
right well I think we have some time for
questions from the audience and I
actually don't have to maybe will to use
the old technology of simply raising
your hand and so I think we have a
couple of microphones available so
there's any questions please raise your
hand I think there's a hand hi I was
just wondering is there Lucifer and
signal strong enough for you to image in
vivo or in tissue section ah that's
question for me I'm guessing yeah that's
a good question so it depends on the
cancer model and the kind of luciferase
that you use the question was could you
for instance image the bacteria inside
of a body or inside of a mouse and all
that signal get out and the things that
you deal with or that if something is
deep-seated in the body it it can't
penetrate the tissue that well and it
depends on the wavelength set of the
signal that the bacteria produce so for
instance one thing that we found is this
is very technical but in these
subcutaneous models that where the
tumors on the skin of the mouse it's
very easy to detect them by using our
equipment but when they're in the liver
and smaller tumors that are more
deep-seated you can't actually see them
that well at least in our case but but
that is a technicality of us using a
blue luciferase which is the shorter
wavelengths and
you can make it a infrared or a red
color that you could actually see in the
lever which we do with ourselves so I'm
getting some signals that maybe we
should tape one question from the
monitor but maybe someone could read it
to us I have I think I got right here ah
or do you want to tell us what what it
is Natasha
even that okay give me the
democratization discussion yesterday
what do we think about programmable
bacteria it's the question thank you
I'll say one thing I want to keep
talking but um so yeah it is interesting
I think there is this idea of like you
know if we have this technology should
we just give it away to everyone or
allow them to work on it and there are
some issues with that and there's a lot
of discussion of who should be doing
this genetic engineering should be
happening inside of labs and
institutions or you know even at home or
at these community bio labs you know to
create your own medicines and things
like that so it's an evolving discussion
that's for sure where we work right now
is more towards the traditional cancer
pipeline of drugs and so you know you
have to develop intellectual property
that will be rigorously tested and
eventually funded by big pharma because
it cost hundreds of millions of dollars
to do these you know multicenter
clinical trials that you can get FDA
approval on so and then at the end of
the day after all of that it costs a lot
of money for that drug even though for
us to make that drug could essentially
be very cheap because growing bacteria
just take some amount of sugars to
produce but to go through that entire
thing you end up in sort of a less to
gert eyes fashion of that programmable
bacteria how do they actually keep you
know Maynard these companies that will
sell you samples right bacteria and how
did they keep them from evolving like
how do you have a like a permanent
identity for bacteria yeah so I think
the most common ways to store store them
and -80 freezers and so those kind of
samples can last 20 years or something
like that and you have to refresh them
but then the actual pieces of DNA
sometimes those are stored at even
higher temperatures and then you put
that into the bacteria so there are all
these repositories that companies have
you can kind of recreate your your
bacteria so it doesn't evolve
well I mean it depends on how it's set
up right so I mean if it is set up on
the theory of the physiocratic kind of
natural limit to growth idea that's the
kind of thing that can be perfectly
aligned with what today we would
consider to be a far right gold standard
type economy right one that is about
hoarding not extending one that is about
you know calling in and building walls
not about extending relations and Rama
fiying out there doesn't need to be a
natural limit to growth if we do it
right right if we consider imagined ways
for it to be not petroleum based if we
can imagine ways for it to be as
infinitely extensible as the kinds of
relations that we can make with each
other and with the things and organisms
around us so I didn't answer the winner
or lose your question but but if it's
imagined in that that particular way I
think that the you know the winners or
those who hoard the winners are those
who you know are the inheritors of the
world of landed property who basically
live off of rents and tolls instead of
off of credit so to speak so that's
that's one answer
if you imagined it in a different way
really as a not as a frozen capital but
as just another set of relations I don't
quite know how you do it number one but
then maybe there's some interesting
possibilities there for a kind of
radical democratized money I think time
for one more question
uh there is one other question I think
that's really about aesthetics and I was
wondering about that as well as I was
listening to all your presentations
anonymous is asking Claire's work has
impact both for its ideas and visceral
beauty but is beauty a necessary
component for a viral art to effect
social change so the rule about
aesthetics
I'm sorry and you will distract that
question again
so Claire's work has impact both for its
ideas and its visceral beauty but its
beauty a necessary component for
environmental art to affect social
change so what would how do you see how
do you think about the role of
aesthetics in and alright in kind of
affecting social change and I have a
very broad sense of experiences I mean
of aesthetics is just kind of refers to
the quality of our experience and I I
don't know I mean you know like what
what do you think I mean I think what
we're doing is what we're trying to do
to me is try to reconstruction right how
how can we re orient ourselves toward
the earth toward our relations whether
they be human or with animal or
bacterial or whatever how do we reorient
ourselves in a way that that that that
is life-affirming you know because we
live in a culture that's almost biocidal
you know it almost really doesn't care
about life and what is a good life well
is it like cars
is it credit card is it gasoline is it
cheap energy is it you know what makes a
good life and we know it's the basic
question of philosophy it has been for
however long you know what about things
like philosophy and so I just think so
culturally I think we as artists are
trying to make propositions proposals
like what if this what if this and i i i
love the the aesthetics of of things
people make i mean it's just it's kind
of endlessly renewable and so yet does
it have to be beautiful you think it's
before i don't know you know like what
is beauty beauty is very socially
agreed-upon thing and it changes things
with history right like who thought that
a tribal mask was beautiful in the
eighteen
century no but types of 20th century
right buddy L Singh
hi I mean I think in your work the you
know some of the bacteria or you know
they have patents they make patterns and
they kind of design their own kind of
aesthetics and so I'm curious how you
think about it yeah it is interesting I
mean I think just as a communication
tool it's very effective to have these
dynamic movies and artworks and things
like that and so we do like to think a
lot about trying to infuse more science
into society and that's obviously
important but but yeah I think that the
aesthetics play a huge role in doing
that especially like the visual arts can
communicate in a way that is uh you know
it sort of transcends language and
boundaries and when you start to tell
people about DNA and proteins that you
lose them very quickly but but with the
artworks you can draw them in and have
them see to see it for themselves and
really see like what what science was
about and what the experience is and so
that's something that we think about a
lot
you know John Maynard Keynes wrote a lot
about aesthetics and has some stuff
around beauty being the surprise right
so it's about the thing that moves the
person somewhere else than where they
imagined they were going to go right so
the former displacing it's great I think
we're out of time so the red light
blinking
I hear that isn't see the sign finis ok
so what we'll do we'll take a half an
hour of a break and we'll reconvene in
half an hour for the next panel at
eleven at eleven o'clock for the next
panel which is invisible all right thank
you
you